[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, my name is Pamela.
I'm the CEO at Stories.
We start building the app
in the US to test the idea.
And now we are working in the
server with Python, Redis,
and Django to host
it in Google Cloud.
With Stories, we want to create
a world [? live ?] library
of [? heard ?] stories.
So we want to get stories
from all the world.
And maybe when you
go to other places,
then you can read stories about
it or know what is inspiring
people to write the stories.
Many people are starting
to do their own challenges.
For example, a
Chilean writer made
"100 [? And ?] Writing Days."
And now she's going
to publish the book.
And because of that,
all people start
to make their own challenges.
For example, with
the special dates,
like Halloween,
users start writing
because they want
to share stories
about Halloween or horror.
And they ask for us to make
a picture of the challenge
to motivate more
people to write.
Everybody has the
stories to tell.
And everybody wants
to hear a good story.
So we were trying to invite
people to share stories
and see the life
with writer eyes.